here's a really important political
story that crosses the the virus story
it crosses 2020 election it crosses the
Democratic primary storyline separation
of powers really a lot of stories are
involved here Democratic Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi is now calling for
the country to vote by mail period now
of course with coronavirus raging and
ravaging the country as we now get into
the phase of the pandemic where the
daily death toll is staggering there are
more and more questions about what's the
rest of the Democratic primary going to
look like but also what's the November
election going to look like a bunch of
Democratic primaries have already been
postponed because of the virus some
states have already decided they are
going to vote by mail or rather some
states already vote by mail others are
trying to figure out what can they do to
get going in that direction but
eventually we're going to get to the
November general election
now I've received dozens and dozens of
emails from people saying is Trump going
to try to postpone the election in
November is Trump going to try to use
the virus to stay in office indefinitely
will it be safe to go out and vote in
November won't the trumpets who don't
take the virus seriously go out and vote
whereas Democrats who are more likely to
take the virus seriously it will stay
home helping Donald Trump getting
helping Donald Trump to get reelected
well of course the answer is we should
be able to vote by mail and Nancy Pelosi
is now saying that's exactly what should
happen which is going to become one of
the biggest political fights since
impeachment here is Nancy Pelosi saying
it on MSNBC yesterday in terms of the
elections I think that will probably be
moving to vote-by-mail that's why we
want it to have more resources in this
third bill that just was signed by the
president to get those resources to the
states to facilitate the reality of life
that we are going to have to have more
vote-by-mail and would hope that we
would have also some funding which was
rejected for the postal service which is
what implement the vote by mail as well
as implementing right now getting
equipment to where it needs to be so
that's very clear she says we need to
vote by mail
the problem is Republicans don't
this Trump doesn't want this Trump
actually said this week vote-by-mail is
one of the package of ideas that
Democrats wanted in the stimulus bill
that would hurt Republicans I won't tell
you this if you look at before and after
the things they had in there were crazy
they had things levels of voting that if
they ever agreed to it you'd never have
a Republican elected in this country
again they had things in there about you
know election days and what you do and
all sorts of clawbacks
and they had things that were just
totally crazy and had nothing to do with
workers that lost their jobs one of
those crazy things that Democrats wanted
in the bill that would make it so
Republicans don't win is people voting
by mail they had things levels of voting
that if you agreed to it Republicans
wouldn't win ever again said Donald
Trump so they know that when more people
vote it's not good for Republicans so
let's talk about how this applies to the
November election we know Democrats are
taking stay-at-home Orders more
seriously than Republicans we know
Democrats are taking the coronavirus
more seriously than Republicans if that
continues if the pandemic persists and
you have to vote in person more
Democrats are going to stay home and
that will allow trumpets to likely get
Donald Trump re-elected because they are
more likely to be ignoring stay-at-home
orders if they even have them in their
states so this is going to be a major
fight it's good that Nancy Pelosi is
bringing this up this should not be
controversial we've had absentee ballots
for years absentee ballots are a form of
vote by mail some people are able to do
it because they can justify it they're
either going to be away unable to vote
in person for whatever other reason
we're talking just about expanding
absentee voting to everyone we have the
system they are going to argue
Republicans that it's too short notice
we simply can't do it we have the
systems in place states already have
vote-by-mail in the sense of absentee
ballots we're simply saying allow
everyone to get an absentee ballot this
is another reason why Trump wants to
open things back up if
things are open it's harder to justify
vote-by-mail if things remain closed
because of the pandemic if states are
still under stay-at-home orders or sort
of shutdown guidelines it is more likely
that Nancy Pelosi would be able to get
her way
on vote-by-mail would be actually a
fantastic modernization of our election
system to switch to 100% vote by mail
people don't need to go stand in line
all bunched together spending sometimes
hours in line voting vote by mail it
makes sense Trump and Republicans know
it's an existential threat for Trump
second term so they will do everything
they can to prevent it but we should do
it we'll continue to cover this and
other stories from today's show on the
David Pakman show
instagram page at david pakman show
while you're on instagram make sure
you're following me for the latest
coronavirus boredom updates on my
Instagram page David Pakman